To illustrate the technique of constraint propagation, let us consider this
figure drawn on a 2D surface. Although this figure has been drawn on a 2D
surface, you and I can almost immediately recognize that this is a 3D cube.
How did we recognize that this is a 3D cube?
How can we help machines do it? Cube is an example of a trihedral object.
A trihedral object is one with three surfaces joined at a particular point,
at this particular point. In general, what [UNKNOWN] a polyhedral surfaces.
A polyhedral surface is one where multiple surfaces join at the same point. So
a soccer ball, with its white and black patterns, is an example of a polyhedral
object because at one point several surfaces can join. A pyramid is another good
example of a polyhedral object. A pyramid has four surfaces joining, at
the apex. So let's do a simple exercise together. Here are six figures all drawn
on a 2D surface. Which of these six figures do you think represents a 3D object?